siamo in un rapporto ragazzi siamo io e
questo uomo e siamo garda andiamo a
vedere il concerto di gianni morandi
comunque ragazzi la cittadina dove
tengono tomorrowland si chiama boom che
in sei video bella tutti i ragazzi in
italia da tutto ragazzi grande tecniche
ma si vede distante questa è l'entrata
di tomorrow nei ragazzi ciao e se sarò
le donne del tomorrow land raganelle
tomorrowland tomorrow fateci un saluto
to mars
[Musica]
se tipo ciardi your phone go cioè se c'è
il telefono scarico ovali e dallo
ricaricano che poi sesta palla che gira
che completamente inutile al cazzo
rebella fa figo quindi
[Musica]
ma non rompere io sono uno youtuber
resta dovete vederla
[Musica]
york
rabbi
va bene non l'ho visto niente però non è
contento anche lui
[Musica]
beh
urgenza pdr signora lei le buccia lenza
quindi per dente per dente affrontata
perché perché perché perché tutti perché
capito che credete che potete credere
grazie
[Musica]
la mia ragazza
stavo giocando
quindi non è che chi gioca pokemon gol
mica è grafica però gioca anche
ve la faccio breve questo idiota ma
buttato le scarpe nel fosso punto in
qualche modo lui dovrà pur fare di
rilanciarne leggermente più vicino l'ipo
essa che fanno la pipì ragazzi con il
bagno sun infatti
viene di merda va a vedere no a farmi
toccare un attimo
no dai grazie marco
chicca non puoi passare di
[Musica]
no no non è vero
lo spagnolo testa di fatica
[Musica]
tomorrow
we are here tutto questo guardate dove
rasko deficiente a riprendere
[Musica]
fabio io vi odio capisco certe
circostante le capisco però questo
la zia jenna paglia secondo me sì anche
un po cagato addosso
[Musica]
[Applauso]
se guardate che cazzo
[Musica]
sai che cosa faccio io adesso che mi
sembra il momento esatto le mani per
pokémon due gatti veramente
lui è un amico conosciuto ha detto
non so chi sia ma è un grande
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ok
l'acqua
[Musica]
adesso proviamo a rimorchiare write
niente
la signora guarda signola bella tutti
ragazzi pisa cioè cosa ne si bagna solo
perché lo sto toccando io la toccato fa
vj
faccio questo effetto alle donne
[Musica]
sì
qui
[Applauso]
[Musica]
raga ma di poche condizioni e di coda
tre ore che dorme e poi è un bordello
allucinante
non mi ha segnato con le cose almeno la
gente lo vede nomi
velina rossa barbarona attenzione
pokemon gol si chiede che cosa ho capito
non è vero internet perché dai trotto
mag mar meramente affanculo
ma dai ma sono due giorni che lo cerco
sto stronzo
[Musica]
il magma tra domanda se in una parola
rete parole sui pochi nomi di una sola
dice la nel mezzo del cammin di nostra
vita mi ritrovai a tomorrow le tante
tante e che tu fai
la stagione di fritti tiri aperti dei
fritti snack sarri sono le 10 martin
garics arriverà alle dieci e mezza devo
trovare un posto decente dove vedere la
console
[Applauso]
e vi pare poco
[Musica]
ok ragazzi e questo è il momento in cui
ho fatto la pazzia vera preso
dall'euforia mi sono letteralmente fatto
caricare sulle spalle da un ragazzo
iraniano che stava vicino a me a caso
io non parlo
paratesto povero cristiano come sa
[Musica]
è questo ragazzi miei era tomorrowland
in questo momento sono le 4 e 20 del
mattino e ho appena finito di montare il
video che avete appena visto ci ho messo
una vita e mezza montalto video però ci
tenevo veramente tanto che venisse bene
quindi non importa a dormire o tre ore
ma [ __ ] comunque è stata
un'esperienza veramente incredibile
tornata a casa avesse riguardato tutti
vi mi sono comprato la compilation
comprate 2 di compilation di tomorrow
lance nelson comprate 3d compilation di
tutti si sono comprato anche le cialde
golose e volevo prendermi soprattutto un
secondo per ringraziare la just
entertainment che mi ha invitato a
tomorrowland sono stati gentilissimi che
praticamente sono un'etichetta
indipendente italiana e rappresentano
appunto i top dj mondiali in italia
soprattutto rappresentano anche il
tomorrowland in italia quindi io non
c'entravo un cazzo in poche parole lo è
sempre stato il mio sogno
loro lo hanno realizzato quindi
veramente ragazzi grazie grazie grazie
sono stati tre giorni non so se i più
belli della mia vita ma tra i più belli
della mia vita sicuramente li lascio
comunque anche i loro linking
descrizione nel caso passate che che
sono delle belle persone dai ragazzi
dopo aver ascoltato il montaggio 10 ore
consecutive di musica e di m posso
andare a dormire 200.000 like
assolutamente per questo migliaia di
video condividetelo con la nonna
condividetelo con kimi che volete ma
condividetelo quindi ragazzi spero che
vi sia piaciuto è come se ti e piaciuto
su un commento è un mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook come nei video tofane
descrizione sensi di scrivere ci vediamo
al prossimo vito bella ragazzi